[موسيقى]
شكرا ايمان
الاصوات مقابله
49.4% للمنافسها الديمقراطي
بالنسبه للمقاعد التي تحسن في مجلس الشيوخ
في اريزون المتارجحه اظهرت النتائج
الاوليه تقدم الديمقراطيين على الجمهوريين
في السباق لمقعد مجلس الشيوخ ووفقا لتلك
النتائج السنه ترا الديمقراطيه
51.4% من الاصوات مقابله 46 فاصله اربعه
في المئه لمنافسه الجمهوريه مصر
الجمهوريين في السباق على مجلس الشيوخ بعد
فرز نحو 77% من الاصوات هذا المرشح
الجمهوري ادم على
49.9% من الاصوات مقابله 47 فاصله اثنين
في المئه للسنه الديمقراطيه كافيسو
كما اظهرت النتائج الاوليه تقدم
الديمقراطيين في السباق على مقعد مجلس
الشيوخ في ولايه جورجيا وذلك بعد فوز نحو
98% من الاصوات
وصوت 49 فاصله اربعه في المئه لصالح
مقابله 48 فاصله 5% لصالح المنافسه
الجمهوري هيرشي
في ولايه
في ولايه بنسلفانيا سيطره الديمقراطيون
على مقعد حاسم في معركه السيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ بالفوز
من الرئيس الشيخ
هذا هو ارجون فتر مالنا اذا وقال حاكم
ولايه جورجيا الجمهوري برايم كيم ان
السباقه على مقعد مجلس الشيوخ في الولايه
يتجه الى جوله الاعاده في السادس من
ديسمبر المقبل
ويبدو اننا نتجه الى جوله اعاده في الوقت
الحالي لا تزال هناك اصوات ينبغي عدها حيث
سنسمح باستمرار ذلك ونرى الى اين ستؤول
الامور لكن من الصعب الانتصار على
السيناتور الحالي
ينظر الينا شبكه مراسلين في انحاء
الولايات المتحده من المجلس التشريعي
المحلي لمدينه اتلانتا في ولايه جورجيا
مراسل الجزيره احمد هزيم من مدينه ميامي
في فلوريدا مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم من
مفضيه في ولايه بنسلفانيا مراسله الجزيره
محمد الاحمد من مدينه نيويورك في ولايه
وسكنس المراسل والجزيره الناصر الحسيني
ومن المركز الرئيسي لفرز الاصوات في
مقاطعه ماري كوبا في مدينه فينيكس في
ولايه اريزونا مراسلتها الجزيره نيسان ابو
كويك ومن لاس
فيغاسله الجزيره فادي منصور كل هذه
الولايات مهمه كنا ننتظر
الامر اذا
نعم نعم اتمنى انتهت المعركه عمليا هنا في
وسكانسن نعرف اذا من هو الفائز فريق يبقى
الفارق ضئيلا جدا بين الجمهوريه رانجونسون
ومنديلا الديمقراطي فريق 100.000 صوت فقط
اذا كان هناك من دروس للجمهوريين او للحزب
الجمهوري في هذه الولايه فان الولايه
بالفعل تشهد والتغييرا على مستوى السكاني
على مستوى نوايا الانتخاب والقضايا التي
تهم من الناقبين صحيح ان جونسون فاز ولكن
فاز بنسبه جدا الى همم ما يدفع الاعتقاب
بان الجمهوريه اذا لم يحسبوا امورهم ولم
يحشدوا المزيد من الاصوات هذه النوع من
البروفا ربما للانتخابات القادمه الرئاسيه
القادمه تعطينا فكره الى اي حد تمكن
الديمقراطيون مثلا بارز مثلا هذا السياسي
الشاب الذي تمكن من الوصول الى همم تقريبا
الى الوصول من الى منصب سنه بفارق 100,000
صوت وبالتالي عده دروس للجانبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري لكن نعم ولكن
ربما ويجب ان ينتبه بالنسبه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه مثلا ولكن هذا ما كنت همم ستتحدث
عنه اعتقد يضل هذا الفوز مهما الى اي مدى
هو مهم بالنسبه للجمهوريه
المهم لان العمليه الحسابيه الان اصبحت
بسيطه وغير معقده الانظار تتوجه تنتقل من
عندي الى واشنطن وباقي الولايات للحصول
على الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ لا الجمهوريه
لديهم 49 اذا ما حصلوا على نفاذه او
اريزونا سيصبح لديه 51 مقاله الاغلبيه
وعلى الرئيس اذا ان يعيد النظر في اموره
وفي اولوياته
نعم هل سيحصلون على نيفادا او اريزونا
لماذا
نسال اذا نسال رساله
اريزونا هناك توقعات منذ البدايه بان
يتاخر الاعلان عن النتيجه في هذه الولايه
الى اين اتجاه الامور حسب استطلاعات الرعد
الراي وحسب ما تتابعينه هناك في ارزون
قبل فجر يوم الجمعه يعني في افضل
التقديرات هنا في هذه الولايه حتى الان
مازال عمليه الاحتساب تجري في هذه الولايه
وخصوصا في هذه المقاطعه ماري كوبا وهي
الاكثرها كثافه سكانيه نحن في مركز الفرز
الرئيسي هنا طبعا هناك دائما تواجد اعلامي
مكثف عمليات الفرز جاريه خلف ربما ترون
قليلا همم عبر هذا همم الجدار الزجاجي
الذي يفصلنا عن عمليات فرز الاصوات ما يتم
فرزه هنا هو الاصوات التي تم تسليمها يوم
امس عبر الاقتراع المبكر لانه كان هناك
طبعا اقتراح شخصي ولكن كان هناك ايضا
صناديق موزعه لكي يضع من طلب قسيمته قبل
يوم ال- الاقتراع يضعه فيها وحتى اللحظه
حسب الارقام التي سمعناها من المسؤولين
المحليين هنا فهناك تقديرات بحوالي
400,000 قسيمه اقتراع في هذه المقاطعه فقط
ماري كوبا من الاقتراع يوم الاقتراع
والاقتراع المبكر ولكن تم تسليم في
اللحظات الاخيره قبل اغلاق الصناديق وهذه
العمليه بمجملها تتطلب عمليه ايضا همم
التاكد من الامضاءات على تلك القسائم
فرزها ثم همم
توقعات الكثيرين ان الدائره ربما تضيق مع
انهاء فرز هذه الاصوات ما بين المرشحين
الديمقراطين والجمهوريين في عده سباقات
بسبب انه كان هناك دفع من قبل الجمهوريين
بدي ان يصوت مناصرهم وانا اخذوهم يوم
التصوير ويبدو ان المرشحين الجمهوريين حتى
اللحظه من تغريدات وتصريحات نسمعها منهم
من بليك ماسترز الجمهوري المرشح لمجلس
الشيوخ انه ما زال يقول انه هناك مسار له
بان يفوز بهذه الولايه وحتى ايضا طبعا
كاري ليك المرشح الجمهوريه لمنصب حاكمه
الولايه مع ان الفارق حتى اللحظه ما بين
ماسترز مثلا
والسنتور الديمقراطي مايكلي هو
89,000 صوت وهو طبعا رقم كبير وفارق لا
باس به يتقدم به كاليما كيتي هابز
الديمقراطيه المرشحه لمنصب حاكمه الولايه
تتقدم فقط باحد 10,000 صوت وهنا تعول طبعا
كاريك التي كانت شككت بنتائج الانتخابات
الصادقه في انها ستحرز همم فوزا وهنا ايضا
تدور تساؤلات ان كان اولئك المرشحين
سيعترفون في النتيجه ان كانت الفارق همم
يضيق
بينهما لدينا الديمقراطين اذا وصل
الديمقراطيون تقدمهم في هذه الولايه ولكن
على الصوره العام اريزونا ولايه مهمه
لمسار الديمقراطيين للحفاظ على مجلس
الشيوخ مع الفوز الذي حققوه في بنسلفانيا
هم بحاجه فقط الى
ولايتين اما اريزونا او نيفادا او اريزونا
وجوجي يعني حسب اي معادله
تتكشف في النهايه ليقوا سيطراتهم على مجلس
الشيوخ لذا هذا هذا
يعني تنصب الانظار عليه بشكل كبير جدا
قضيه التشكيك برزاهه الانتخابات كانت
متواصله معنا منذ الامس وحتى يعني ساعات
الفجر همم اليوم من قبل البعض بسبب
المخاوف الجمهوريين المتعلقه بهذه الولايه
ان يخسرها لذا اا يعني الساعات المقبله
ستكون حاسمه جدا هنا عثمان
معنى من هناك ولكن افه دي ساتركك قليلا
لمزيد من التسويق ربما ولذهب اولا لابن
سيلفينيا التي حزم الامر فيها وخسر المرشح
الذي كان مدعومه من الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب بقوه ونتحدث هنا عن نعمه اوز
وفازه هناك جون فترمان المرشح الديمقراطي
محمد
اوز نشر قبل قليل بيان مكتوب اقر فيه
بخسارته في هذه الانتقادات واشار فيه ايضا
الى انه اتصل بالمرشح الديمقراطي جون بيتر
مان مهن اياه بالفوز بهذا المقعد ايضا اوز
في نفس البيان وفي مساء مستمر لتصوير نفسه
بانه سياسي جمهوري
معتدل ووسطي دعا الى وضع همم
الاختلافات الحزبيه جانبا والتركيز على
القضايا التي تهمه
ايضا السنه الذي يتاهب يتقاعد للسنه
الجمهوري همم
المرشح الديمقراطيون بيتر مان خوضه
يعني تنافس في هذه الانتخابات وعليه كان
التنافس بين كل من جون بيتر مان وايضا
ميمتر وتقاعد همم باتومي للاشاره فقط
عثمان جاء بسبب تصويته في الواقع على
محاكمه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب نيابيا
في مجلس الشيوخ وقرار تقاعده قارئ على انه
ضغوط من التيار الترامب والجمهوريين همم
في الحزب لذلك القرار لكن عمليا هذا
الانقسام بين
التقليديين همم الجمهوريين التقليديين في
المؤسسه وبين تيار ترامب قد يكون كلف
عمليا عثمان الحزب الجمهوري هذا المقعد
المهم هنا في بنسلفانيا خاصه ان
الديمقراطيين باتو يمتلكون حاليا عضويين
في مجلس الشيوخ عن الولايه هذا بالاضافه
الى النجاح الذي حققه المرشح الديمق طيب
الجو شابيرو لمنصب حاكم الولايه في
بنسلفانيا هذه الولايه الحاسمه هذه
المكاسب الديمقراطيه على صعيد مجلس الشيوخ
وايضا على صعيد حاكم الولايه قد تسوق من
جانب الحزب على انها واحده من النجاحات
الكبيره في هذه الانتخابات بالنظر الى
اهميه بنسلفانيا سواء في هذه الانتقالات
وايضا في انتخابات 2424 هناك ايضا تقارير
يتم تداولها في الاعلام المحلي عن ان
ترامب غاضب جدا من خساره من اوس في هذه
الانتخابات وبدا بتوجيه اللون لبعض الذين
اوصوه بدعم المرشح الجمهوريه اوزع علما
بانه للتذكير عثمان كان هو السبب الرئيسي
في ليل بطاقه الترشيح الحزب عن همم
بالرغم من الشقوق والمخاوف التي تولدت لدى
كثيرين بشكل شخصيه من خارج الحزم شخصيه
اعلاميه ولا يسكن اصلا في ولايه بنسلفانيا
وبالتالي يمكن ان يوجه اللون بحسب ما يرى
كثيرون
في هذه الخساره الى الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب خاصه في ضوء الاداء غير الكبير جدا
لمن دعامهم في هذه الانتخابات سواء هنا في
بنسلفانيا او في ولايات حاسه
عثمان همم
بدانا نستمع الى اصوات جمهوريه القبلاء
على الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في اختيار
بعض المرشحين الذين يعتبرون انهم لم
يكونوا المرشحين همم اقوى تحديدا في
بنسلفانيا مع خساره نذهب الى فادي منصور
في نيفادا فادي اذا ايضا بعد ان ذهبت بن
سلفانيا
الديمقراطيين ووسكون سن رغم ال همم يعني
كان المنافسه كانت محتاج ما فيهوش سكان
ولكن على كل حال ذهبت الى الجمهوريين الان
على اريزونا وعلى جورجيا وحتما على نيفادا
فماذا يحدث في نيبال
ناموا عثماني بدا بعد لم تكشف اوراقها
بالكامل والمعسكران الديمقراطي والجمهوريه
حاذران كثيرا في التعامل مع النتائج
المرشحه الديمقراطيه التي تدافع عن مقعد
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ كرتاج ماستو
اصدرت بيانا يوم امس قالت انها سوف تنتظر
نتائج النهائيه والتي قط تتطلب اياما لكي
تظهر بشكل نهائي وتفصيلي لكنها اعربت عن
الوثوق بامكانيه الفوز في هذه الولايه
المهمه للغايه في المقابله المعسكر
الجمهوري وايضا على لسان المرشح الجمهوريه
الذي ينافس على موقع مجلس الشيوخنا في
الولايه المدعوم بالكامل من الرئيس دونالد
ترامب والذي خاض هنا في ولايه نيفادا
معركه قطان بنتائج انتخابات عام 2020
المرشح الاجداد ايضا اعرب عن تفائله
بالفوز لكنه ايضا كان حذرا وقال انه سوف
ينتظر النتائج النهائيه الذي حصل خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه هو انقلاب
المعادله هنا في نيفادا عثمان بعد التقدم
الذي كان يحوز عليه الديمقراطيون انقلبت
الايه الان قليلا بنسبه نحو 2.5% لصالح
الجمهوريين مع تقدم لكن حقيقه ما يجري حتى
هذه اللحظه هو ان ما جرى فرسه من اصوات
يتعلق باصوات التي اخترعت بشكل شخصيه يوم
امس بالاضافه الى الاصوات عبر البريد وهي
الاغلبيه التي كان جرى فرزها قبل يوم
الانتخابات لكن يظل هناك نحو 200.000 صوت
مما جاء في البريد والذي ايضا سوف ياتي من
الان وحتى يوم السبت المقبل اا 200,000
صوت تتركز في بقعتين جغرافيتين الاولى هنا
في مقاطعه كلارك حيث توجد مدينه لاسفاجاس
والاخرى في مقاطعه وشو حيث توجد مدينه
رينو هذا يمنح املا كبيرا للديمقراطيين
لان هاتين المنطقه الطين عاده ما تفضلان
وتتوجهان ديمقراطيا
في الثالث وبالتالي على الورق هناك
امكانيه اكبر لحضور الديمقراطيين لكن كما
اشارت هناك حذر كبير في التعامل مع
النتائج في كل الاحوال من الواضح ان
المعركه لم تكن سهله بالنسبه للجمهوريه
حتى هذه اللحظه ويبدو ان هناك سؤالان
اساسيان طرح واحد قبل قليل خلال المداخلات
وهو ما الاثر الذي الاثر لترامبي على اداء
الحزب الجمهوري في هذا الانتخابات في ظل
رياح عاتيه كانت تواجه لحزب الديمقراطي
الرئيس هو من اقل الرؤساء شعبيه خلال
السبعين سنه الماضيه مع حلول الانتخابات
النصفيه ارقام متدنيه للغايه وضع اقتصادي
يقلق الناس حاله من التضخم غير مسبوقه منذ
40 عاما وبالتالي نظريا كان ينبغي يخرج
جمهوريين ان يكتسح او يحقق نجاح كبير في
هذه الانتخابات النصفيه هذه القضيه الاولى
مثلا المساله الثانيه هل اخطا الجمهوريون
بخلق قضيه الديمقراطيين هي قضيه الاج بعد
عمليه الاوراق الاساسيه ورقه الاقتصاد
والتضخم ليست لصالحهم تبين في استطلاعات
راي ان القضيه الاولى هي الاقتصاد والتضخم
ولكن القضيه الثانيه فيما يتعلق بالناخبين
هي مساله الاجهاض وبالتالي هذا سؤال ثاني
مهم هل اخطا الجمهوريون بدفع هذه الورقه
وجعلها قضيه تمكن الديمقراطيه من حشد
الاصوات حولها لا سيما هنا في ولايات
نيفارا اعتقد ان هذه الاسئله كلها فاديه
طرحها الجمهوريون على انفسهم بالفعل لانهم
حققوا نتائج رغم همم ان الاغلبيه ربما
يحفظون بها في مجلس النواب ولكن هي بدرجه
اقل كثير من الذين كانوا يتوقعونه وما زال
السباق مستمر بالنسبه لمجلس الشيوخ
بالنسبه للفلوريدا كانت النتيجه الجمهوريه
ولكن لها دلالات همم معينه ايضا مراد ما
الذي يمكن ان نقراه في النتائج التي ظهرت
في ولايه
نعم بالفعل عثمان ااا لا شك ان الفوز
الحاكم
هو اهم ما قدمته
في الانتخابات النصفيه
فيما على مستوى البلاد هناك اهتمام واسع
بهذا الفوز بقيه النتائج السباقات الاخرى
كانت متوقعه
وصدقت فيها الكثير من الاستطلاعات
والمؤشرات مع استثناء بسيطه
ليست في صالح الجمهوريين همم ولا الى ما
كانوا يتطلعون اليه همم على سبيل المثال
فيما يتعلق بما قاعد الولايات في مجلس
النوابس وصف نصره همم بانه انتصار العصر
وشكرا مواطني همم وقال انهم لم يحققوا
كسبا في هذه الانتخابات
لكنهم غيروا الخارطه همم السياسيه ولهذا
الكلام له دلالاته لسانتس يناى بنفسه عن
خوض اي مواجهه كلاميه مع ترامب رغم ان
ترامب يصعد اتباعا وهو وجه رساله واضحه
للسانس لدي سانتوس يوم امس
حينما حذره في مقابله مع فوكس نيوز من خوض
السباق وقال انه يعلم عن لسان تسال كثير
مما لا يعلمه همم الاخرون همم بما في ذلك
همم زوجته همم وكان في السابقه لانه في اي
سباق مع لسان تسفا انه سوف يغلبه وصف
لسانه سابقا بانه
كذلك شكك في شعبيه
لم يدعوه الى مهرجان الانتخابي رغم ان
ترامب صوت الاديسانتس وادعم بشكل سريع
وعرضي الجمهورينا للتصويت لصالحه لكن
الواضح انه يخوض معركه خطابيه من جانب
واحد ينقل حاكم بنفسه عنها يركز على حملته
وعلى استقطاب دعم المحافظين الجمهوريين
عثمان
حسنا احمد هزيم معنا من جورجيا جورج
احمد انت معنا اذا من جورجيا ايضا ان هناك
كثيرون يقولون ان جورجيا ربما هي التي
تكون نتيجتها النتيجه الحاسمه همم هل اصبح
من المؤكد ان تكون هناك دوله اعاده ثانيه
من ليس بالضروره
نعم عثمان لم يعلن رسميا لكن جميع الاوساط
هنا في جورجيا وحتى شبكات الاعلام
الامريكيه من الفرنسيه
وضعت هذا السباق في خانه جوله الاعاده
في السادس من ديسمبر المقبل هناك مؤتمر
صحفي بعد اقل من ساعه لسكرتيره الروايه
يتوقع ان يعلن فيه عن ان هذا السباق سيتجه
الى جوله عاده لان كلا المرشحين لم يتمكن
من الحصول على اكثر من 50% مع وجود مرشح
ثالث 80,000 صوت همم بالنسبه اثنين فاصله
اثنين بالمئه من اصوات الناخبين سيخرج هذا
المرشح الثالث وبعدها يتجه المرشحين الى
جوله اعاده ل- همم الكشف عن همم من هو
الفائز بهذا المقطع وربما الفائز بال-
الحزب الفائز في الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
لكن ايضا النظره بما اننا تحدث الزملاء عن
تاثير الترامبيه السياسيه على مرشحي الذي
دعامه رئيس همم السابق دونالد ترامب اذا
اخذنا راديسون برغر دخل هذه الانتخابات
ايضا كسب مرشح لسكرتير الولايه او حاكم
الولايه همم برايم كامب الذي دخل امام
السيسي اذا نظرنا لارقامهم وفوزهم السهل
على خصومهم الديمقراطيين وتعثر هيرش
الووكر وعدم قدرته على مجارات هذه الارقام
هناك اكثر من 300,000 صوت تفرق بين
كيمب وبينرجي»
السياسيه لانها بقيه ال- ال- المرشحين
الجمهوريين كانوا من الذين عارضهم الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب لانهم او
اعتبرهم لم يساعدوه على قلب نتائج جورج
وسوف الذي كان حاكما ان ذلك بينما هو دعم
بقوه قرش الووكر في هذه الانتخابات وهرش
بنى حملته الانتخابيه على مقاصد ترامبيه
السياسيه سواء من انكار نتائج الانتخابات
او من الحديث عن همم
كيلو الشرطه
ومعارضه الهجره وغيرها من هذه المواقف
للترامبيه هذا هذا السباق عثمان ذاهب الى
همم الى جوله عاده سيحدد ربما الاغلبيه في
مجلس
ننتظر وانار اذا عموما شكرا
جزيلا لكم جميعا نتابع معكم ايضا في ساعات
المقبل احمد هزيم من جورجيا محمد الاحمد
في بنسلفانيا
شكرا جزيلا
تاريخيا شكلت الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه التي تجرى في منتصف ولايه
الرئيس محطه لتصويت عقابي ضد حزمه حزب
الرئيس لم يحدث ان فاز فيها حزب الرئيس
الذي يكون موجود في الحكم الا مرتين
اثنتين من اجمالي 17 موعدا انتخابيا منذ
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه لذا يطرحوا
عدم تحقيق الجمهوريين فوزا كبيرا في
الانتخابات الحاليه اسئله بشان الواقع
السياسي والاقتصادي والاجتماعي الامريكيه
الذي قد يجعل منها استثناء ان يخالف
القاعده
لم يحدث المد الاحمر الذي توعد به
الجمهوريون باتجاه الانتخابات النصفيه الى
وضع المتارجح لا يمنح انتصارا صريحا للحزب
الجمهوري فان احد اكثر الانماط ثباتا في
التاريخ السياسي الامريكي في الطريق لان
يكسر وهي خساره حزب الرئيس بعد سنتين من
توله منصبه اعتاد الناخبون الامريكيون
اتخاذ هذا الموعد الانتخابي فرصه للتصويت
في ما يشبه الاستفتاء على شعبيه الرئيس
فبعد عامين على وصول الديمقراطي باراك
اوباما الى البيت الابيض عام 2008 خسر
الديمقراطيون 63 مقعدا في مجلس النواب
خلال انتخابات التجديد النصفي عام 2010
وعلى نحو مماثل ومعهود خسر الحزب الجمهوري
واحدا واربعين مقعدا في مجلس النواب عام
2018 اي بعد سنتين من انتخاب دونالد ترامب
رئيسا للبلاد
وعلى امتداري تاريخ الانتخابات في
الولايات المتحده منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه عام
1945 الى اليوم خسر حزب الرئيس في 17
موعدا للانتخابات النصفيه التي تجرى في
منتصف الولايه الرئاسيه من اجمالي 19
موعدا انتخابيه كانت تصويت في جل
الانتخابات اجراء عقابيا يقره الناخب
الامريكي في حق الرئيس
عاده ما تتدنان نسب شعبيه الرؤساء في
منتصف ولاياتهم الرئاسيه فاذا كانت نسبه
شعبيه بعيدا حاليا في حدود الاربعين في
المئه فان النسب المماثله حصل عليها سلف
هدونالد ترامب عام 2018 وبارك اوباما عام
2010 وقبلهما بالكليتون عام
بات الطريق سالكا الى كسر القاعده محاطه
بعوامل مؤثره على خيارات الناخب جرت
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه هذه السنه
فالمناخ السياسي والسثنائيون الى حد كبير
في ظل مخاوف على الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
لاسيما وان ميول بعض المرشحين الجمهوريين
واضحه نحو التطرف الى اقصى اليمين يضاف
الى ذلك قضايا اجتماعيه ملحه تشغل المواطن
الامريكي وعلى راسها الحق في الاجهاض الذي
ابطله قرار للمحكمه العليا شهر يونيو
الماضي ويبدي الحزب الديمقراطي نزوعا نحو
السعاده
ينضم الي في الاستوديو الدكتور اسامه ابو
رشيد الباحثه المتخصص في الشؤون الامريكيه
اهلا وسهلا وكذلك معنا الدكتور استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعتها ورد وعرض
وحركه تقدم المجتمعيه دكتور جود ورد كانت
الارضيه مهيئه تماما للجمهوريين
ليحققوا موجه حمراء ريدوي كما يسمونها
ولكن هم لم يفعلوا ذلك يعني
رغم تقدمهم في مجلس النواب الاصوات
الجمهوريه التي نسمعها اا يبدو عليها
الكثير من خيبه الامل وهذا ملفات لماذا لم
يحققوا الفوز الذي كانوا يطمحونه اليه
على اليوتيوب
لا سيما في اول عهده لاي رئيس في مجلس
النواب نرى هذا الحزب يخسر الكثير من
المقاعد في العام 94 خسر وفي 2010 خسر 64
وفي 2018 خسره 38 ربما 10 مقاعد خسيرها
ديمقراطيون وهذا عدد قليل هناك عدد من
الاسباب اولا هناك الكثير الاداء
الاقتصادي الذي يتوقع الجمهوريون ان
يساعدهم لم يقنع الناس بتغيير اصواتهم من
الديمقراطي الى الجمهوريه ثانيا المحكمه
العليا الامريكيه قد اثر قرارا منعت في
الاجهاض وهذا كان غير شعبي وسعد
الديمقراطيه هذا هما سبب عن رئيسيه لعدم
تحقيق الجمهوريين مع كلمه طموحنا اليه كما
حصل في السنوات السابقه
دكتور اسامه ما ما رايك ما ماذا تعني هذه
النتيجه من الواضح انه
الجمهوريين سوف يسيطرون او ستكون لهم
اغلبيه في مجلس النواب ولكن برقم اقل كثير
مما كان متوقعا ومما يحدث عاده تاريخيا في
الانتخابات النصفيه في الفتره الاولى
للرئيس كان يتحدث سيد ويد ورد عن 10
والمتوقع كان 30 او اكثر
لا شك ان هذا يعني ايضا صعوبات بالنسبه
للحزب الجمهوري وليس فقط في الحزب
الديمقراطي في الحكم لانه العامين
القادمين اذا افترضنا ان ان همم سيطرون
على مجلس النواب على الاقل لا نعلم عن
مجلس الشيوخ الى الان فانه من المتوقع ان
يجعل ان يعطلوا او يلجا الى تعطيل اجنده
الذي سيجري الان في ظل اقليه همم اغلبيه
باقلليه هذا سيعص- سيعقد ايضا من قدره همم
زعيم الجمهوريين على ان يقود اصلا الحزب
الجمهوري داخل مجلس النواب لانه هناك
متشددا يسمون الفريدوم هاوس المحسوبين على
دانو ترامب الذين سياخذون الاوامر منه
سيعقد عليهم حتى المعارضه وقد يدفعهم
الثمن مره اخرى في عام 2024 الذي جرى هنا
ان ال الناخب الامريكي كان امام خيارات
صعبه الاصل ان يخسر الديمقراطيون 90% من
ان 90% من الناخبين يقولون القضيه الاولى
بالنسبه لنا الاقتصاد لكن ايضا هناك عشر
ملايين وظيفه وضيفت خلال سنوات همم هناك
الخوف على الديمقراطيه ودعم ترامب ل 300
مرشح مما لا مما لا يعترفون بنتائج 2020
وقد يشكك ببعض النتائج هذه الانتخابات وقد
يشك ويثير ازمه دستوريه في 24 عندنا عدد
من الانجازات التي حققها الديمقراطيه سواء
البنيه التحتيه او ما يتعلق بالشبه
الموصلات او ما يتعلق مثلا بتمكين النظام
الرعايه الصح الحكومي من التفاوض على
الادويه هذه الامور بالنسبه للناخر دفعته
ان يفرق بين بين الذي لا يحظى بشعبيه
عاليه وبين المرشح الذي استطاع ان يقدم
نفسه ديمقراطيه بعيد عن عن سجل الرئيس
الديمقراطيه انك ذكرت يا دكتور الخوف من
الديمقراطيه لانه دكتور وردي كان هناك من
يلوم الرئيس بعيدا عند حديثه عن الخوف من
الديمقراطيه والتركيز على هذه النقطه في
الوقت الذي يعني كانت استطلاعات الراي
تقول فيه ان اهتمام الناخب الاول هو
الاقتصاد هو التضخم هل كان محقا اذا وهل
هذا بالفعل هو ما اسهم في همم اكيد ليس
هزيمه الجمهوريين ولكنهم همم ربما قد يقول
بعض همم فوز بمذاق الهزيمه ربما
بالنسبه الى الرسائل كان لدينا استراتيجيه
مختلفه الجمهوريون ركزوا على الاقتصاد
والتضخم المرتفع حوالي ثلاثه في المئه او
ثمانيه في المئه
والبطاله هي 3% لكن ارتفاع تضخم اعتبره
الجمهوريون اساسا حتى يركز الناخبون على
تصويت جمهوريه بعكس الديمقراطيين الذين
ركزوا اكثر على الاجهاض
يبدو اننا موضوع الاجهاض
فينو وايزونا وفين سلفانيا قد بهم الى
الرفدي الحكام
[موسيقى]
الذين هم جمهوريون ربما بايتن كان حكيما
في حشد الديمقراطيين
تحضيرا للانتخابات التي ستاتي بعد سنتين
داخل مجلس النواب اريد ان افهم اكثر هل
تعني ان كبر مكارثي رئيس
البحرين
الاكثريه سيجد عمله معقدا للعمل في الحزب
في مقابل
ترامب يعني داخليا داخل الحزب الجمهوري ام
العمل في في جهه مضاده للحزب الاخر الحزب
الديمقراطيس سيجد نفسه همم ان دائره
المناوره امامه او مساحه المناوره داخل
الحزب الجمهوري ضيقه وعندنا تجربه حقيقه
في عام 2010 عندما اصبح الجمهوريون في
الاغلبيه وكان اوباما هو الرئيس لم يستطع
رئيس مجلس النواب في ذلك الوقت ان يتعامل
مع التيار الحزب الشاي في ذلك الوقت لانه
كان يتبنى اجنده متطرفه جدا اتطرف المحصله
ان لا يترشح مره اخرى لانه مره اخرى عندما
لا يكون لديه اغلبيه واسعه بحيث انه لو
خسر 10 على سبيل المثال لو كانت الاغلبيه
25 الى 33 مقعد كما كان يتوقع قبل
الانتخابات في ايام عندها يكون لو خسر 10
اصوات من اللي ما يسمى الفريده هاوس عند
ان يمكن له ان يتبقى لديه نفس الاغلبيه
لكن ان خسر 10 اصوات الان او سبع اصوات او
سته اصوات لا نعلم كم سيحصل الجمهوريون كم
ستكون همم فارق الاغلبيه اذا خسر خمسه او
سبعه او عشره اصوات هذا يعني انه لا يملك
اغلبيه داخل مجلس النواب وسيصبح عندنا
حزباني اقليه وليس حزب اغلبيه وحزب
الاقليه وهذا كله نتيجه عامل ضاله ترامب
ضاله ترامب همم يريد ان يحول الحزب
الجمهوري الى حاله من الطائفيه انه زعيم
طائفه وهذا التنافس داخل المستويات
حوله وعامل دونالد ترامب الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب دخل هذه المعركه الانتخابيه
رهانات عده لكن العديد من المرشحين الذين
دعمهم لم يحالفهم النجاح كان هناك مثال في
بنسلفانيا على ذلك
عن مشجن واماكن اخرى وهما يطرح اسئله بشان
مستقبل ترامبا سياسي وفرص ترشحه للرئاسه
عن الحزب الجمهوري في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في 2024
[تصفيق]
اخرجه الحدث
دونالد ترامب يظهر من جديد دون ان يملا
الصوره وحده فلم يعد الرئيس الذي كان
وانما هو الطامح للعوده الى الرئاسه من
بوابه نصر ينشده في انتخابات الكونغرس
المصريه
في جهود حزبه الانتخابيه
لكنه وهو الداعم لثلاث مئه وثلاثون مرشحا
جمهوريا لا يبدو مستعدا لتلقي اللوم على
هزيمه اي منهم
اعتقد انه في حال فوزهم سيعود الفضل كله
لي واذا هزموا فلا ينبغي لهم على الاطلاق
لكن عاده ما يحدث العكس انا مستعد لاي شيء
وسندافع عن انفسنا الدفاع هنا عن خياراته
ورهاناته لخوض معارك انتخابيه بدت لكثيرين
معاركه الخاص في كثير منها لم يتحقق النصر
الذي تمناهود
بل خابت اعمالك كثير من مرشحه المفضلين
والمؤيد كثير منهم كما يعتقد لاجدده حركه
ماركه
كسب الديمقراطيون مقعدا حاسما للسيطره على
مجلس الشيوخ بفوز جون فترمان الذي يتعافى
من جلطه الدماغيه في ولايه بنسلفانيا ذات
الاهميه الانتخابيه الكبرى
كان فوزا على حساب المرشح الذي اختاره
دونالد ترامب بعنايه الدكتور محمد اوز في
واحده من اكثر المعارك تنافسيه في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه جدا
[تصفيق]
حتى اكبر انتصارات الجمهوريين حين تاتي
تابى ان تحمل توقيع ترامب فكيف اذا كان
الانتصار المدوي من نصيب منافسه المحتمل
على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري لرئاسيه 2024
رون ديسانتس حاكم ولايه فلوريدا الجمهوري
اعيدا انتخابه للمنصب بنتيجه مبهره
لن يجد ترامب في فوز الرجل ما يستدعي
لاحتفال اما نتائج بقيه من دعم ترشحهم فلا
يبدو انها تخدم خطته لخوض السباق الرئاسي
المقبل
ان يجعل من انتخابات الكونغرس النصريه
نقطه ارتكاز لاطلاق حملته بعد ايام
المقربون منه ما زالوا يعتقدون بقدرته على
تدجير كل حظا عاثر لمصلحته
حسنا عامل دونالدز ترامب دكتور بود ورد
كثيرون من الذين دعمهم دونالد ترامب خسروا
في بنسلفانيا في مشكن هناك
في الريزونا ما الذي يعنيه ذلك بالنسبه
لتاثير دونالد ترامب داخل الحزب الجمهوري
وفي الناقب الامريكي بشكل عام
سؤال سؤال الوطني
[موسيقى]
تاثير لكن هو دخل في مواجهه مع اعضاء
الحزب الجمهوري وربما هذا هو السبب الذي
افضى الى خسارته هؤلاء المرشحين
لما وصفته انت بعامل ترامب لانه بالاضافه
الى المرشحين الذين دعامهم وخسروا وكان
هناك ايضا
الذي يبرز اسمه بقوه في الترشح للرئاسه في
2020 و24 عن الحزب الجمهوري وهو ااه فاز
بنتيجه تاريخيه انجاز التعبير كان فوزا
كبيرا له في ولايه فلوريدا طيب عندنا عده
مستويات هنا واحد دائما متربي يمثل معضله
مزدوجه للحزب الجمهوري هذه المعضله
ابتعاده يعني اذى عنده خزان بشري مؤيد له
وعنده 60% من الحزب الجمهوري الى الان لا
زالوا يدعمون ترشحه لكن
6% من المستقلين يريدون ان يرونه مرشحا قد
يفوز بالانتخابات الجمهوريه لكن سيخسر
الانتخابات العامه على الاقل بناء على
الارقام الموجوده لكن ابتعاده ايضا يعني
انه ستخسر الخزان البشري الذي وراءه 76
مليون صوت له الان فيما يتعلق براند دي
سانتوس راندي سانتوس هو صنيعه ترامب في
الانتخابات قبل اربع سنوات عندما انتصر
فقط ب 30,000 صوت كانت ترامب هو الذي دعمه
هو الذي رشحه لكن بعد ذلك بدا ياخذ خطا
مساره مستقلا ويرى نفسه الزعيم القادم بعد
هزيمه
هو النسخه المطوره والذكيه عن دانه
والتربه هو يعني هذه هذه هذه النقطه يمكن
تحتاج نقاش اخر لكن الذي جرى ايضا انه
انسان الى الان لا زال هو مرشح فلوريدا
وفيلوريدا تم تغيير الكثير من القوانين
فيها التي افادت الجمهوريين واضعفت
الديمقراطيين اضعفه الاقليات وكان هناك
قوانين فيها تعدي على حقوق بعض الاقليات
مثل السود في الانتخابات هذه افادته في
الانتخابات هل هذا يعني انه سيترجم على
المستوى الوطني هذه مساله سينبغي ان ننتظر
لنرى ما هي النتائج التي ستكون في اي
انتخابات لو تنافس الطرفان هل لو جهه تهم
جنائيه هل هذا سيضعفه ام لا هل سيكون هناك
صفقه له مع ادعاء ام لا هذه امور كلها صعب
نحسب بها من الان شكرا دكتور اسامه الباحث
المتخصص في شؤون الامريكيه وشكرا كذلك
الدكتور
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعتها ورد
وحركه التقدم
المجتمعيه سنراقب عن كتب اذا الارقام التي
تاتينا بخصوص هذه همم ان نتائج خاصه في
اريزونا وهمم النفاذ جورجيا نرى ما الذي
سوف عوده الى الدوحه وبقيه ملفات التاسع
على ان عوده اليكم في الحصاد في تغطيهنا
المستمر
[موسيقى]